hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live
wandert Donald Trump hinter Gitter in
den USA hat gestern Abend eine grandjury
für seine Anklage gestimmt dass ich ein
amerikanischer Ex-Präsident vor Gericht
verantworten muss das ist neu das hat es
noch nicht gegeben und darin steckt eine
enorme politische Sprengkraft wieso
weshalb warum darüber wollen wir heute
reden und zwar mit unserem Washington
Korrespondenten MRT Wissen und mit dem
us-rechtswissenschaftler Kirk Junker
schickt gerne eure Fragen und Kommentare
schreibt ihr am besten direkt in die
Chats oder schickt uns eine E-Mail die
ganze Sache ist nicht unkompliziert
deshalb hat Sie Claudia Welt für uns
zusammengefasst
vor der Staatsanwaltschaft New York ein
Polizeiaufgebot sie bereiten sich nach
der Anklage gegen Donald Trump vor auf
mögliche Proteste
wir werden Zeugen amerikanische
Geschichte zum ersten Mal wird ein
Ex-Präsident einer Straftat beschuldigt
das gab es noch nie es geht um
schweigegeldzahlungen an die
Pornodarstellerin stormy Daniels von der
Trump Organisation falsch deklariert als
Anwaltskosten und möglicherweise
illegale Wahlkampffinanzierung da das
Geld eingesetzt wurde damit die Affäre
Trump bei der Wahl nicht schadet Donald
Trump nutzt die Anklage um sich als
Opfer politischer Verfolgung zu
inszenieren auf seiner Social Media
Plattform bezeichnet er sie als
Hexenjagd als Attacke auf das Land und
der Republikanern wird ihm die
Strafverfolgung vielleicht nutzen aber
ich denke bei einer breiteren
Wählerschaft wird es ihm Schaden bei
Menschen die dieses Drama satt haben
auch wegen des Umsturz Versuchs nach der
letzten Präsidentschaftswahl wird noch
gegen Trump ermittelt hier geht es um
deutlich schwerwiegendere Vorwürfe
Donald Trump hat seine Anhänger
aufgehetzt er hat mit Tod und Zerstörung
gedroht wenn er jetzt angeklagt wird ich
denke es wäre gefährlicher wenn wir
nicht der Rechtsstaatlichkeit folgen
würden
voraussichtlich am Dienstag soll Donald
Trump zu verlesen der Anklage vor einem
Richter erscheinen wo er wohl auf
unschuldig plädieren wird
jetzt haben wir schon mal einen
Überblick und schalten jetzt nach
Washington zu MRT wissen
guten Morgen Elmar bei dir ist es noch
relativ früh deshalb kann ich guten
morgen sagen ja das Trump angeklagt
werden soll das ist gestern nach unserer
Zeit am sehr späten Abend bekannt
geworden und war dann ja doch irgendwie
eine Überraschung oder
das hat alle überrascht weil in den
letzten Tagen eigentlich der Anschein
erweckt wurde als wäre die Grand Jury
auf dem Sprung in den Osterurlaub man
hatte einen nach außen hin durchsickern
lassen gewissermaßen dass es wohl erst
in drei Wochen weitergehen würde und das
haben sogar die Anwälte von Donald Trump
geglaubt auch einige von denen so hören
wir hatten geplant selber in den
Osterurlaub zu fahren weil sie nicht
damit rechnen dass noch was passiert und
dann kam es gestern anders alle wurden
überrascht alle mussten schnell ihre
Statements im Grunde genommen noch
schreiben um darauf zu reagieren und
Donald Trump hat natürlich dasselbe
gesagt oder verbreitet was in den
letzten Wochen schon gesagt hat nämlich
dass es eine politische Hexenjagd sein
okay also das wird für einige Beteiligte
gewesen sein mit dem Osterurlaub aber
lass es uns mal aufdröseln im Groben
geht es um schweige Geldzahlungen an die
Pornodarstellerin stormy Daniels und mit
der soll Trump auch eine Affäre gehabt
haben worauf stützt sich die Anklage da
genau
also das Schweigegeld selber ist
überhaupt nicht illegal das wäre kein
Problem für Donald Trump gewesen aber er
hat das Geld quasi durch seinen so ist
jedenfalls die Behauptung durch seinen
fixer oder Anwalt bezahlen lassen
Michael Coon und hat diesem Anwalt dann
eben das Geld erstattet und dieses Geld
dann deklariert als Anwaltskosten und
ich als das was es in Wirklichkeit waren
nämlich schweige Geld und damit könnte
er einerseits verstoßen haben gegen gute
Buchführung denn er hätte in seiner
Buchführung tatsächlich den wahren Zweck
angeben müssen nicht Anwaltskosten und
das zweite dadurch die Grundlage also
durch dieses frisieren der ähm
Geschäftsunterlagen hat er die Grundlage
gelegt um zu verschleiern wofür das war
und er hätte dieses Geld auch nach dem
amerikanischen Wahlgesetz als
Wahlkampfhilfe indirekte Wahlkampfhilfe
im Wahlkampf um die Präsidentschaft 2016
diese Einigung gab es ja kurz bevor die
Wahl dann stattgefunden hat hätte er das
deklarieren müssen dieses
zusammengenommen so wird vermutlich die
Anklage sein ist nicht nur ein Vergehen
sondern eine Straftat das Dumme ist wir
kennen diese Einzelheiten noch nicht
weil das Urteil der Grand Jury ist
derzeit versiegelt das heißt streng
geheim und wir werden es möglicherweise
erst erfahren wenn Donald Trump am
Dienstag abend deutscher Zeit 20 Uhr dem
Haftrichter in New York vorgeführt wird
Trump jetzt auf diese Nachricht reagiert
und was gibt es darüber hinaus für
Reaktionen
ja Donald Trump selber hat natürlich
gleich mit der großen Keule
zurückgeschlagen dass seine politische
Hexenjagd hinter verschlossenen Türen
sagt der seinen Unterstützern dass dies
ihm im Wahlkampf wahrscheinlich auch
massiv helfen würde aber öffentlich eben
immer mit den Worten dass das noch nie
in der Geschichte vorgekommen sei das
sei der Versuch die nächste Wahl zu
manipulieren einzugreifen in diese Wahl
und Donald Trump verbindet dann das
immer gleich auch mit Spenden aufrufen
weil er behauptet dass er eben hier das
Opfer sei er hat dann entsprechend über
Social Media Plattformen verbreitet dass
man ihn doch dann Geld spenden sollen
ihm in diesen Kampf unterstützen soll an
andere Republikaner haben sich auch
schon geäußert führende Republikaner wie
Kevin McCafé im amerikanischen
Repräsentantenhaus der eben auch von
einer politischen Verfolgung spricht
selbst Runde Sand ist das ist der
Gouverneur von Florida der
möglicherweise einer der schärfsten
Gegenkandidaten für Donald Trump im
Rennen um die Präsidentschaftskandidatur
nur sein wird der sagte das sei eben aus
politischen Gründen gewesen und das
diene ganz offenbar dazu den politischen
Gegner fertig zu machen auch Mike Pence
der ehemalige Vizepräsident hat sich
geäußert er glaubt das sei ein
unglaublicher Vorgang der vor allen
Dingen dazu beiträgt dieses Land noch
weiter zu spalten aber es gibt auch in
der republikanischen Partei ein zwei
moderatore Stimmen zum Beispiel der
Gewinner von arkansizer hutschen sind
der ebenfalls als
Präsidentschaftskandidat wohl antreten
wird er sagt nun hat eine Grand Jury
entschieden das ist ein
rechtsstaatliches Verfahren und man muss
sich jetzt eben genau ansehen auf
welcher Grundlage die Jury das
entschieden hat und dann eben dem
rechtsstaatlichen Verfahren freien Lauf
lassen gibt es denn auch schon
Reaktionen aus dem Umfeld des
amtierenden Präsidenten journeiden
nein haben wir noch nicht gehört es gibt
eben Reaktionen aus dem amerikanischen
Kongress ich sag mal enge Verbündete
auch von Joe Biden Joe Biden setzt alles
daran und die Administration dass sie
nicht in Verbindung und mit unmittelbar
gebracht werden mit den Vorgängen in New
York Joe Biden macht gewissermaßen
business as usual er wird wahrscheinlich
auch öffentlich nicht kommentieren weil
er vermeiden will dieses Bild dass es
sich hier um eine im Grunde und
politisch motivierte Verfolgung handelt
was sie nicht ist es geht hier um die
Frage dass ein amerikanischer oder ob
ein amerikanischer Präsident über dem
Gesetz steht viele harder natürlich
damit das ausgerechnet dieser Fall der
erste ist wo Anklage wohl erhoben wird
weil es gibt mindestens drei andere sehr
schwere Fälle der eine ist der rund um
die Ereignisse vom 6 Januar der zweite
um die Dokumente die Donald Trump mit
nach Malaga und Florida genommen hat und
der dritte um seinen versuchte
Einflussnahme auf Wahlbeamte in Georgia
und das sind alles viel schwerwiegendere
Fälle bei denen vielleicht eine Anklage
einfacher zurechtfertigen wäre aber
jetzt ist es eben der Fall um stormy
Daniels der als erstes zu einer Anklage
führt absolut und auf diese anderen
Fälle werden wir auch gleich noch mal zu
sprechen kommen wenn ich mal in die
Community schaue da gibt es durchaus
stimmen die das gut finden Michael
schreibt geschieht ihm auch recht Hans
schreibt ein Verbrecher wie Trump muss
hinter Gitter gebracht werden Jakob sagt
ich denke dass erhöht seine Chancen auf
die Kandidatur seine Wähler fühlen sich
dadurch nur bestärkt und Trump wird das
Ausschlachten du sagst es ja auch Trump
inszeniert sich als Opfer spricht von
einer Hexenjagd wird ihm dieses ganze
Verfahren am Ende vielleicht sogar
nutzen
das ist nicht auszuschließen es kommt
glaube ich darauf an inwieweit im
Wahlkampf andere bereit sind dem
rechtsstaatlichen Verfahren den Vorrang
zu geben und auch klar dieses
verteidigen Donald Trump selber wird
sich weiter als Opfer darstellen es gibt
innerhalb der republikanischen Partei
allerdings eben auch eine Absetzbewegung
innerhalb der letzten Monate war das
schon sehr deutlich zu sehen viele
wünschen sich weniger Drama und damit
eben am besten kein Donald Trump als
Präsidentschaftskandidaten
die der die Republikaner haben man
sicher ein Problem tritt Donald Trump am
Ende an also ist er dann der gewählte
Präsidentschaftskandidat für die
republikanische Partei dann fehlen ihm
möglicherweise am Ende die Wähler die
sagen wir wollen dieses Drama nicht mehr
und er ist wirklich nicht der durch den
man sich vertreten sehen will auf der
anderen Seite wenn Donald Trump nicht
antritt und jemand wie ronde Sand ist
dann Kandidat würde dann werden ihm
möglicherweise umso mehr eingefleischte
Donald Trump Anhänger fehlen die im
Grunde sagen er hat recht er ist hier
das Opfer und für die dann Donald Trump
der einzige ist den sie als
Präsidentschaftskandidaten akzeptieren
würden
imkerliche Grüße möchte wissen wer hat
was davon dass Trump dann im Knast sitzt
wenn er dann in den Knast kommt naja
also das darf ja eigentlich nicht
Grundlage in einem Rechtsstaat sein
inwieweit man davon einen politischen
finanziellen oder anderen Nutzen hat
wenn man feststellt ob ein Präsident
über dem Gesetz steht oder nicht das
heißt wenn er für seine Taten zur
Verantwortung gezogen wird dann sitzt
der möglicherweise am Ende im Gefängnis
nicht wahrscheinlich für diese Anklage
jetzt weil das war mit maximal zwei
Jahren Haft bewährt wäre dieses
Verfahren aber mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass vor Gericht
nicht einfach wird so etwas
durchzusetzen am Ende käme es vielleicht
zu einem Bußgeld vielleicht auch
Bewährung aber wenn er verurteilt würde
dann wäre er eben ein verurteilter
Straftäter und nach dem amerikanischen
System das klingt verrückt ist aber so
könnte Donald Trump weiter als
Präsidentschaftskandidat antreten er
könnte sogar die Wahl dann gewinnen und
Präsident werden er wäre dann der erste
als Straftäter verurteilte amerikanische
Präsident er darf nur dann selber nicht
wählen aber er darf gewählt werden das
klingt verrückt aber das ist in den USA
so absolut da schreibt auch Paul schon
ziemlich skurril dass man in vielen
Bundesstaaten nicht wählen darf wenn man
im Gefängnis war aber man darf eben
Präsident werden
wenn ich noch mal in den Chat schaue da
schreibt Sven könnte man Trump in Haft
nehmen lassen wenn er zu Gewalt und
Aufstand aufruft und das ist insofern
eine ganz wichtige Frage denn wie hoch
schätzt du die Gefahr ein dass er seine
Anhänger wieder so aufsetzt wie beim
Sturm aufs Capitol 2021
die Gefahr ist groß wir haben das ja in
den letzten Tagen schon gesehen er hat
schon gepostet auf Social Media dass sie
das eher tot und Zerstörungen im Grunde
genommen sieht wenn tatsächlich er
angeklagt wurde oder gar verurteilt
wurde dafür das ist im Grunde eine
indirekte Aufforderung zu Gewalt und das
ist am Ende eben nicht einfach schlüssig
vor Gericht dann nachzuweisen man kann
jedenfalls für diese Äußerung alleine
ihn nicht in Haft nehmen wir sehen das
ja auch bei den Ereignissen rund um den
6 Januar da läuft das Verfahren und man
wird sehen ob es dann überhaupt wirklich
zu einer Anklage kommt versteht dass er
am Dienstag eben in New York auf
schlagen muss er muss kommen zum Gericht
in New York mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
wird er nicht den Handschellen gelegt
der Secret Service der ihn ja immer noch
schützt ist dagegen dass dieses eben
passiert das heißt man wird Fotos von
ihm machen man wird seine Fingerabdrücke
nehmen der wird dem Haftrichter
vorgeführt möglicherweise auch an den
Kameras an den Medien vorbei geführt
werden das ist eben gerade recht hören
wir aus seinem Umfeld weil er eben damit
auch am Ende Wahlkampf machen kann aber
mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit würde er
dann nach dieser Anhörung am Dienstag
auch gleich wieder auf freien Fuß
gesetzt weil er natürlich für nicht
schuldig plädiert keine Fluchtgefahr
besteht aus Sicht des Gerichts und dann
mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit er sich
ganz normal wieder in den Wahlkampf
stürzen kann
dazu schreibt Barbara der hat bestimmt
gute Anwälte und kommt dort Heil raus
und Karl sagt Trump wird gar nichts
passieren der wird irgendeine Summe X
zahlen und geht dann Golf spielen wie
wahrscheinlich ist sowas in den USA
ja es ist ein Strafverfahren das heißt
hier ist der Staat ja unterwegs gegen
einen Angeklagten und da kann man sich
nicht einfach mit einer ich sag mal
finanziellen Einigungen rausreden das
ist erst bei eher bei Zivilklagen
natürlich die Möglichkeit das heißt die
hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit ist dass dieses
Verfahren bis zu Ende durchgeführt wurde
wenn der Richter ist tatsächlich zulässt
weil der Haft Richter muss dann
entscheiden bzw das Gericht muss dann
entscheiden ob es tatsächlich
ein ein Fall ist der verhandelt werden
muss natürlich werden die Anwälte von
Donald Trump am kommenden Dienstag bei
dieser Anhörung genau diesen Antrag
stellen nämlich dass dieses Verfahren
abgewiesen wird weil man eben sagt dass
gar nicht genug Beweise dafür da sind
dass es überhaupt keine Absicht belegbar
ist in diesem Fall und das
möglicherweise die Anklagepunkte noch
mal die wir nicht im Einzelnen kennen 30
insgesamt soll es sein sind noch
versiegelt dass diese an Klage Punkte
eben gar nicht auf das was tatsächlich
passiert ist zutreffen darüber muss ein
Richter entscheiden und dann werden wir
sehen ob es tatsächlich zu einem Prozent
kommt letzte Frage an dich einmal heute
Morgen hieß es mal dass aus
Justizkreisen verlautet hätte dass
Donald Trump aufgefordert wurde bereits
heute vor Gericht zu erscheinen für wie
wahrscheinlich hältst du das du sprichst
von Dienstag
ja das ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass er
auch heute vor Gericht erscheinen würde
aber es deutet sehr vieles darauf hin
mehrere Quellen die sagen dass für
Dienstag Viertel nach zwei Ortszeit in
New York tatsächlich diese
dieser
Ereignis vorgesehen ist dass er sich
selber stellt und dass er dann eben im
Haftrichter vorgeführt wird die Polizei
hat zur Sicherheit aber auch heute schon
die entsprechenden Schutzmaßnahmen
erhöht alle Beamte in New York müssen
heute in Uniform erscheinen die
Schichten sind voll besetzt man schützt
das Gerichtsgebäude sehr intensiv das
wird auch über das Wochenende so
weitergehen und ich wage mal die
Prognose dass wir am Dienstag noch eine
deutliche Erhöhung der Schutzmaßnahmen
in New York selber sehen werden aber
auch in Washington da hat man in den
letzten Tagen schon Zäune um das Kapitol
herum aufgebaut um sicherzustellen dass
Donald Trump Anhängern nicht
möglicherweise das wiederholen was wir
am 6 Januar 2021 hier erlebt haben also
man versucht auf entsprechendes
Szenarien diesmal vor bereitet zu sein
Elmar ganz lieben Dank für dieses
Gespräch und du hältst uns bitte weiter
auf dem laufenden tschüss
tschüss ja also diese Anklage wird wohl
kommen da steht fest dass es aber bei
weitem emma ist ja eben schon
angesprochen nicht der einzige
juristische Ärger den Donald Trump hat
und Alexandra hat ihn hat einen
Überblick
einst ganz oben scheint es für ihn nur
noch abwärts zu gehen im Sog der Justiz
denn gegen Donald Trump wird von allen
Seiten ermittelt in fast zwei Dutzend
Fällen vier strafrechtliche
Untersuchungen könnten besonders
gefährlich für ihn werden da sind zum
einen die Ermittlungen der
Staatsanwältin in Georgia wegen
Wahlbeeinflussung bei der
Präsidentschaftswahl 2020 fehlen Trump
in den Bundesstaat nur knapp 12.000
Stimmen zum Sieg er will um jeden Preis
im Weißen Haus bleiben und greift zum
Hörer versucht Georgias Innenminister
einen Republikaner dazu zu bringen ihn
Trump zum Sieger zu machen
ich will einfach nur
11.780 Stimmen finden eine mehr als wir
haben weil wir den Staat gewonnen haben
hat sich Trump beim Versuch die Wahl zu
kippen strafbar gemacht zu dieser Frage
hat eine Grand Jury vor kurzem ihren
Bericht abgeschlossen jetzt muss die
Staatsanwältin in Atlanta entscheiden ob
Anklage erhoben wird
eine weitere Untersuchung zur Wahl 2020
die Attacke auf us-kapitol am 6 Januar
stürmt ein wütender Mob das
Kongressgebäude um die Bestätigung von
Joe Biden zum neuen Präsidenten zu
verhindern
angestachelt von Donald Trump
wir gehen zum Capitol und wir werden
kämpfen wie der Teufel
welche Rolle spielte Trump beim sechsten
januar und wie hat er versucht das
Wahlergebnis zu fälschen das
Justizministerium hat einen
Sonderermittler in der Sache beauftragt
dieser Sonderermittler befasst sich noch
mit einem weiteren Fall Mara Lago
FBI-Agenten durchsuchen im vergangenen
August Trumps Anwesen in Florida und
finden diverse Geheimdokumente manche
top secret mindestens 15 Kisten mit
Unterlagen hatte das National Archiv aus
Marmelade schon geborgen hat Trump im
Umgang mit den Dokumenten die nationale
Sicherheit gefährdet das
Justizministerium ermittelt und
schließlich der Fall der Staatsanwalts
in Manhattan der Anklage erhebt in einem
Video an seine Anhänger streitet Trump
alles ab
[Musik]
diese vier schrecklichen Ermittlungen
der linksradikalen Demokraten gegen
euren lieblingspräsidenten ist nur die
Fortsetzung der ekelhaftesten Hexenjagd
in der Geschichte unseres Landes
alle Vorwürfe gegen ihn für Trump nichts
als Fake News
ja ob das so einfach diesmal wird das
einfach als Fake News abzutun darüber
wollen wir jetzt sprechen mit dem
us-rechtswissenschaftler
schönen guten Tag guten Tag Herr Junker
vielleicht vorab die Frage die über
allem steht und auch immer wieder in der
Community kommt Joachim fragt wie hoch
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass er dafür
ins Gefängnis muss
ja also dieses Spekulation ist sehr
schwierig man könnte wissenschaftlich
anschauen wie viele Leute in der
Vergangenheit in diese Lage dann
beurteilt sind und Gefängnis sitzen aber
die sich schon uns berichtet haben also
diese andere Leute waren nicht Donald
Trump die war nicht die ehemalige
Präsident der USA
in dem Sinn ich glaube auch ein Richter
muss dann entscheiden ob es nicht nur in
diesem Fall sondern im allgemeinen wenn
die amerikanische juristische System
wirklich gut wäre ein ehemaliger
Präsidenten Gefängnis zu sehen
unterscheiden wir noch mal ganz klar
also welche Auswirkungen auf die
Präsidentschaftskandidatur hätte die
Anklage und welche Auswirkungen eine
Verurteilung
ja die einer Anklageerhebung hindert
niemanden daran kein politisches Amt für
kandidieren selbst wenn ein Person
verurteilt wird kann er wie
ihr Korrespondent aus Washington
berichtet hat immer noch ein Amt
kandidieren aber auch komischerweise er
darf nicht wählen aber er darf in beide
Situationen immer noch aus
Bundespräsident aus Kandidat sitzen wir
haben aber zweimal schon mindestens
zweimal in der Vergangenheit
Beispiele gesehen wo genau solche Leute
nach ihr Verurteilung und Nazi in
Gefängnis waren wieder gewählt sind sind
in Washington selber in Washington
der der Bürgermeister Marian
war verurteilt wegen Kokain und Drogen
saßen Gefängnis kam zurück und es war
wieder gewählt und dann 10 20 Jahre
später 2014 in Bundesland Louisiana der
gouvernor Edwin Edwards nach keine
zehnjährige Haftstrafe wegen
organisierte Kriminalität
den ersten Platz bei den Vorwahlen für
den
us-präsidentenhaus
bekam hat also es wäre nicht undenkbar
okay durchaus bemerkenswert wie das
manchmal da funktioniert ähm damit wäre
auch die Frage von Prinzessin Diana von
Baden beantwortet die ihm gefragt hat
ist das Thema Präsidentschaftskandidatur
2024 damit endgültig vom Tisch nein ist
es nicht ähm Herr Junker wenn ein
Staatsanwalt ein Ex-Präsidenten anklagt
dann muss man doch davon ausgehen dass
seine beweise ich und stichfest sind nun
kennen wir die Anklageschrift noch nicht
genau das haben wir gehört aber gehen
Sie davon aus dass dem dann auch so ist
die Anklageschrift bedeutet das genügend
Beweise vorliegen um die um den
Angeklagten zu verhaften nur das es
bedeutet nicht dass der angefragte des
Verbrechen schuldig ist und ein
Staatsanwalt muss sich selber dann
überzeugen dass genug Beweise nur dafür
ist
und in dem Sinn natürlich nach der
Verfassung würde man erwarten dass bei
jeder nicht nur Donald Trump gibt's
genug Beweise um jemand zu verhaften
wir haben es jetzt eben gesehen es gibt
noch weitere Vorwürfe gegen Trump bei
welchen Fällen sehen sie eine große
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es auch dort zu
einer Anklage kommen wird
ich meine wir sind in Georgi in genau
der gleiche wie wie in New York
vielleicht für die für die Zuschauer ist
es wichtig zu verstehen dass
us-ferralismus ist anders als in
Deutschland also Förderalismus in den
USA bedeutet für diesen Fall dass
Straftaten sind ländersachen nicht
verursachen und deswegen was er in New
York gemacht hat ist durch den New York
der Sony aus als Schaf gebracht oder
auch in Georgien und dann die anderen
die sind doch dann Verl aber wir wissen
immer noch nicht was passiert wird weil
die nur noch in untersuchen sind
eine der ersten Reaktionen von Trump auf
die Anklage war ja dass er erstmal zu
Spenden aufgerufen hat und dazu gibt es
auch eine Frage aus dem Chat weiß man ob
Trump sich den Wahlkampf überhaupt
leisten kann und macht er vielleicht
deshalb so enorme Stimmung also wie
wichtig ist in den USA Geld für um so
einen Prozess mit mit Anwälten überhaupt
zu finanzieren
ein bisschen mehr aus in Deutschland
aber im Allgemeinen ist es nicht nur für
für für diese Frau in New York wie wir
schon erwähnt haben Georgia
was mit in Malaga passiert hat 6 januar
und es gibt auch sie will Prozesse die
gegen ihn geführt sind ich meine im
allgemeinen er hat wirklich eine
Handvoll von Problemen die manchmal in
verschiedene Ländern sind manchmal vor
den Bundesgerichten sind und manchmal
einfach sie will Probleme sind nicht
strafprobleme also insgesamt er braucht
ihre Anwälte jetzt und die haben alle
andere Gerichtsbarkeit die sind nicht
die die die gleiche Team von Anwälte die
in jede Gerichtsbarkeit ihm
repräsentieren kann
was passiert jetzt im weiteren Vorgehen
was sind die nächsten Schritte
also in New York es gibt zwar in solchen
strafzahl es gibt drei verschiedene
Schritte die erste haben wir schon
gestern gesehen das bedeutet dass ein
Grand Jury muss dann genug Beweise
gefunden haben und haben sie um ihn
erfahren zu haben aber er Hafen zu haben
in dem Sinn ist für Donald Trump auch
ein bisschen anders wenn jemand
freiwillig sich abgibt und planmäßig am
Dienstag sehen dann muss die Polizisten
nicht hinfahren muss er nicht in
Handschellen braucht er nicht diese
sogenannte work machen die Leute jenige
die die sich freiwillig abgeben kommen
einfach vor dem Gericht
Fingerabdruck fotografiert werden und
dann lern letztendlich äh was der der
Richter dann vorlesen wird was genau
bewiesen ist von für die für die Grand
e
da gibt es noch eine Frage und zwar nach
der Spaltung Amerikas also wann hört die
Polarisation in Amerika auf ähm der User
findet dass es eher schlimmer statt
besser wird und befürchtet dass der
Prozess ähm die Situation noch weiter
verschaffen dürfte
tja also ich bin
also juristische Wissenschaft und das
ist eher eine politische Frage aber ich
glaube politisch gesehen es kann sein
dass es vielleicht für eine kurze Zeit
doch schlimmer wird aber
wir haben schon heute mehrmals erwähnt
ob jemand wirklich über den Gesetz steht
und das zu testen jede Demokratie muss
das machen also allein hier in Europa
Schal Cousine
beide sind verhaftet und dann jetzt
unterwegs in in Pakistan mit ähm kann
wenn jemand ein Jahrhundert
es ist wichtiger für ein Gesellschaft zu
zeigen ein demokratische Gesellschaft
dass sie die Fähigkeit haben jemand vor
dem Krieg zu bringen auch eine Präsident
ist oder Präsident war und das niemand
unbedingt gesetzt steht
es gibt noch eine Frage aus dem Chat
wann werden Ergebnisse erwartet also
gehen Sie davon aus dass Donald Trump
und seine Anwälte versuchen werden
dieses Verfahren in die Länge zu ziehen
ja natürlich ohne wird sie haben früher
von von Geld gefragt er wird
wahrscheinlich sein Geld benutzen um all
die die mögliche Methoden zu benutzen um
Zeit zu kaufen und dann werden wir
natürlich diese Probleme haben wenn er
immer noch Kandidatur hat dann sind wir
näher dran diese diese Wahlkampfzeit und
dann
politisch gesehen gibt's dann druck das
jemand der so nah dran ist für den
Wahlkampf soll nicht vor dem Gericht
gepackt werden
das das könnte vielleicht politisch
passieren aber vor allem sie haben schon
erwähnt auch dass sofort nach seine
seine eigene Medien Prost letzte Woche
weltweit hatten jede von Donald Trump
zwei Tage lang von von Opel verhaftet
wird gesprochen nur wer weil er allein
aus seiner eigenen Medienplattform ein
Post gemacht hat er ist vor allem ein
ein Media ein TV Showman er weiß genau
wie das ganze System eine Pionieren kann
also in dem Sinn wo ich sagen ja das
können wir wahrscheinlich erwarten
absolut und rutsch schreibt auch dazu je
mehr Publicity umso besser für Trump
letzte Frage an Sie weil auch das damit
zusammenhängt kann es passieren dass
dieser Prozess öffentlich gemacht wird
und Millionen dann vor den Fernsehern
oder im Netz verfolgen werden wie Donald
Trump vor Gericht steht ja praktisch
Verfassung ist es erlaubt das ist aber
eine Entscheidung für für den Richter
oder die Richtung und zu sehen ob es ein
ein Prozess weitergeführt werden ohne
Vorteile Vorteile gegen den verklagter
oder gegen den Staat also wenn wenn das
wirklich nicht fair wird weil so viele
Medien Interesse da ist dann können Sie
das abschließen und wie gesagt
wirklich vor allem ein Thema ist ich
kann mir gut vorstellen er wurde das
eigentlich
liebe sehen also nichts sehen dass er
jeden Tag
kostenlose Zeit an Fernseher hat
ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich für Ihre
Informationen und ihre Einschätzung ich
wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen Tag
tschüss
ja und damit verabschieden wir uns ZDF
heute live zur Anklage gegen den
Ex-Präsidenten Donald Trump für wünschen
euch noch ein schönes Wochenende macht's
gut bis bald tschüss